I don't like how tight that color isn't
high up but we're gonna get to that
we're gonna get to that because it's a
bad fit now listen or got Bab I know is
it's a bad is a bad fit or you waste in
the way no no I got a good body
I I have a good body I just intermittent
fast which is why I stay so oh okay cool
skin stay I'm gonna post about my Wilbur
show and what I do if you see become
where I get it faster I'm gonna come at
you that's in Boston now we know that
that's one of my ears ease
that's one of my time you're also mine
from Pasadena you've never been to
Boston as to this outside why this
outside your Southie no you're not
whatever it is I'm from the south side
New Jersey I'm from the south side of it
you understand what I'm saying
see you had some edge thank you
so what I'm saying is yeah in Boston I I
did and I'm not trying to brag on just
do it on a fax guy you know my fax guy
numbers like I say the facts right I'm
just a guy who was just coming out did
[ __ ] yeah coming out the gate with just
[ __ ] rip horn blazing with facts okay
I know okay so so um I did I did I did
five I did five shows at the Wilbur at
the Whooper theater and it's like oh
yeah no and it wasn't even on New Year's
Eve right so it wasn't like an extra
special thing it was just I think it was
like a Tuesday and okay so if you were
at my show and you also like Bryan
Callen some people that listen to this
podcast right that that don't that
aren't D'Elia fan and after this are
people who there are a few well but
there are I'm objectively we know I'm
objectively not to be a dick okay he had
the instrumentation we had the
instrumentation with two different
instrumentations with due to non button
non partisan okay monitors right right
didn't we and and we had to see who who
got the biggest laughs in the long stop
oh yeah well hold on and it doesn't
matter I want right
the night and then I said hey Chris
after the show after I'd destroy that
went hey Christ and you go yeah and
there was no energy in your arms
remember arms you looked up at me and
you went yeah and I didn't here I go I
do yeah and I go how it's done remember
I ran to you and I go and when you said
that when you looked at me and you said
that's how it's done I go like this no
I'll show you next time and you go like
and I remember looking at you and and I
thought and I was like why does you why
do your genes have the you know what
Australia looks like where it kind of
comes down on the side and then up on
its countlessly it has horns and stuff
and I was like why do you have an
artist's drawing of Australia on the
front of your jeans and i realized you
pissed yourself it was a piece of like
why do you have on the front of your
jeans the map of Australia right and I
and I got closer no and I thought but
patchwork doesn't smell like piss right
these camel pants yeah on there and
because I gave you the best right I give
you the [ __ ] and when I really talk to
you when I get Stern and when I [ __ ]
barreled you know when I get one hand on
my hip and I go like that I'm giving you
the best right oh my god you're going to
eat the Australia man you are I'm going
T tau whole [ __ ] went TT Australia
that's what happened do it right any to
[ __ ] you up bro yeah you will yeah cuz
it comes a time when a man decides to
drop it all and stop talking and he just
he just neutralizes the stares that
right to it and you've never have
anybody never in your life had you ever
had anybody neutralize the situation
because you didn't do sports your
theatre guy your theatre did musical
theater and you never got you never
gotten to mix up dude I better to mix up
man what
I was like [ __ ] say sixteen
well they one thing with substance okay
one smart thing like what like Boyd what
area what arena tell me about the
impeachment it doesn't it's not gonna
matter it's not gonna matter he's gonna
be President and the impeachment made it
so he's gonna be president in 2020 fair
point fair point
how about that for substance hey why is
this it's like he's a paraplegic which
is good he's like this Stephen Hawking
relax you're gonna criticize line dude
I'm not gonna criticize him dude look
what I am sweating so Ted of my arms
sweaters annoying this guy asks for a
media might hurt sales dude do you think
about that bro and you sold a lot of
this you think this I could sell a dick
to a firefighter okay yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]